welcome back okay in the last video we
talked about what is the high level goal
of balanced model reduction which is to
find some coordinate transformation from
a high dimensional state X to a low
dimensional state X tilde that captures
the most input-output dynamics from you
to Y because that's all I really care
about for control because I can affect
you and I can measure Y now before we
get into finding this what this we're
going to call this the balancing
transformation we're gonna this this is
a coordinate transformation that
balances controllability with
observability before we get into that I
have to tell you how dynamical systems
have these linear state-space models
change under a change of coordinates so
what we're gonna do essentially is we're
gonna look at what happens X equals I'm
going to draw this as a big square
matrix T times Z so this is a reduced
state X tilde first what we're gonna do
is we're going to look at what happens
just if I do some coordinate
transformation T so this is an
invertible matrix t that all it does is
just changes my x coordinates to z
coordinates or vice versa we're gonna
see what happens when we what happens to
these dynamics when we do this
coordinate transformation and then we're
gonna pick a very very special T that
balances that takes my controllability
Graham Ian and my observability Graeme
in and under this coordinate
transformation we're going to find that
there are special coordinate
transformations that make those Graham
Ian's equal and diagonal so I can
basically find a coordinate
transformation I'm going to draw this
this is a super important picture so
maybe I have a controllability Graham
Ian I'm gonna draw this as an ellipsoid
in state space so this is my most
controllable direction that's my least
controllable direction maybe I have an
observability Graham Ian like this okay
pointing in a slightly different so this
is let's say OB SV this is Graeme an
observable this is let's call this CTR B
this is my W C Graham Ian okay maybe
that isn't gonna come through WC my
controllability Graham Ian then what's
really amazing is that there exists a
coordinate transformation T a special
one out of all the possible invertible
matrices t there's a very special one
that essentially changes the coordinate
so that both of these Graham Ian's are
equal to this pink Graham an and then
this becomes in these new coordinates WC
equals wo equals a diagonal matrix Sigma
and this diagonal matrix is ordered from
most controllable and observable to
least controllable and observable and
this gives me a very clear way of
truncating if I only want you know one
state or two states I pick the
directions that are most jointly
controllable and observable so in this
case I would pick this direction because
that is the most controllable and
observable direction and I would
disregard this direction and so we're
gonna find that specialty matrix we're
then going to pick a subset of those
columns and we're going to call that
side that'll be our balancing
transformation okay so that's what we're
gonna do we're basically going to find a
special coordinate transformation that
makes my controllability and
observability Graham Ian's equal and
diagonal that's going to give me a
hierarchy of my state space in terms of
the most jointly controllable and
observable States to my least jointly
controllable and observable States so
from highest to lowest and that gives me
an easy way of drawing a line and saying
if I want to keep five modes if I want a
five dimensional representation that
most captures the controllability and
observability I can just pick the first
five columns of T and that's my balance
and transformation okay that's where
it's going right now I'm going to tell
you how this dynamical system and have
these graeme ins change under a
coordinate transformation to you so if
this is a little fast we're gonna go
back through this we're actually gonna
code this up and visualize it in MATLAB
and we're going to go through finding
that coordinate transformation to you
that does this it's very related to
eigen decomposition so it's like
eigenvectors t is essentially going to
be a fancy set of eigenvectors okay
super simple basic concept what we're
gonna do is we're going
to write this dynamical system in terms
of a new variable Z where x equals T Z
okay so what is what does this actually
do okay so X dot is T times Z dot right
so essentially I'm just gonna say I'm
just gonna basically every time I see an
X I'm going to replace it with the TZ
super simple so I'm gonna say T Z dot
equals a times T Z plus B U and Y is
gonna equal C times T Z this is really
simple it literally just took this and
every time I saw an X I plugged in a TZ
i took the time derivative and T is a
constant so it doesn't get a dot but Z
is a variable it gets a dot ok so TZ dot
now remember this is a full coordinate
transformation this is a big invertible
matrix it's an N by n matrix T so we're
going to left multiplied by T inverse to
get just my Z dot equations so now what
I'm going to get is Z dot equals T
inverse a T Z plus T inverse B u and why
isn't going to change it's just C T Z
and so now what's cool about this is
these these essentially give me my new a
B and C matrices in my Z coordinates so
in my Z coordinates this is my a matrix
this is my B matrix and this is my C
matrix so I think what I'm going to do
is I'm gonna just call those hats I'm
gonna say any a B and C matrix and Z
coordinates are a hat B hat and C hat so
finally I'm gonna say let's group these
this is one set of equations two sets of
equations Z dot is a hat Z plus B hat u
and y equals C hat Z where a hat is just
T inverse a T B hat is T and
B and C hat is C times T okay
that's pretty simple okay now if the
columns of T are orthonormal then T
inverse would be a T transpose and this
T inverse would be a T transpose so if I
had a very special transformation T
where it was not only invertible but the
columns are orthonormal meaning that the
inner product of any two columns is
equal to 0 unless that inner product is
that column with itself then this
inverse is even easier than T inverse or
just BT transpose okay so that's a nice
thing that you can do with these
coordinate transformations okay so this
is really really simple I can just do a
change of coordinates with an invertible
T let's make a little note this is
important this is invertible okay
because it's a big square matrix it's a
real coordinate transformation it's not
a truncated state if I had this
coordinate transformation T then I can
write my dynamics in these new Z
coordinates pretty simply in terms of
ABC and T ok now what I want to tell you
what's really important is understanding
not only how this affects the dynamics
but how this affects the graeme ins this
is the most important part okay because
what we're going to be doing is we're
going to be trying to design a very
special tea that does this that takes
these graeme ins that makes them equal
equal and diagonal okay so I'm going to
do my best attempt at trying to write
down what all these grammy ins are here
and it's a little bit you know involved
so this is gonna be some math so bear
with me so what I want to do is I want
to write down what is the Grammy in in
these coordinates and my Z and hat
coordinate system and again you can go
back to the controllability bootcamp the
control bootcamp and remember what is
this WC so I'm gonna say WC hat I should
have probably called this a hat so let's
call this hat hat right we're gonna find
this new coordinate transform that makes
my hats
do a special thing okay so what is my
controllability Graham Ian I think it's
an integral from time 0 to time infinity
of integral from time 0 to time infinity
of okay I'm cheating a little of e to
the a tau b b okay i'm gonna do star
that means complex conjugate transpose
so if I happen to have complex valued
dynamics which happens in quantum
mechanics this is the complex conjugate
transpose for any real valued dynamics
this is just a transpose I want you to
let's let's put a note star equals
complex conjugate transpose so for all
real systems this is just a transpose
times e to the a complex conjugate
transpose tau D tau okay and remember
these are hats variables this is a hat B
hat B hat a hat okay remember what I'm
trying to do I have dynamics those
dynamics have controllability and
observability graeme means I want to
know how did the dynamics change in a
new coordinate system and how do the
graeme ins change in a new coordinate
system that's all we're gonna do right
now
then we're gonna design that coordinate
transformation to have good properties
so this is the controllability Graham
Ian's in my a hat B hat C hat
coordinates okay
now what we get to do is expand a hat is
really T inverse a T and B hat is T
inverse B so it's gonna get a little
messy whoo all right let's try it I'm
gonna give myself a little more room
here this is an integral from 0 to
infinity of e to the t inverse a T tau
okay B hat is T inverse B okay B hat
transpose is B hat transpose is B
transpose T inverse transpose
okay this is gonna be a B transpose T
inverse transpose I'm gonna just do -
star but you're gonna have to remember
that is literally T inverse transpose I
just invented this well I didn't invent
it but this is just notation this means
T inverse transposed and then I need my
e to the T inverse a T tau D tau Wow
not great not terrible either okay that
is what my controllability granion and
z-coordinates looks like in terms of my
original ABC and T matrices now the cool
thing is I can pop because I'm going to
assume that this is somehow kind of an
eigenvector or an orthogonal I'm going
to assume that this this this T inverse
I can pop out of this exponential which
I can so I'm going to pop out my T
inverse on both sides of everything so
I'm gonna pop my T inverse I'm gonna
have my integral I'm gonna get integral
0 to infinity e to the a tau times the
matrix T times T inverse those cancel
times BB star T - star T - 1 e to the a
Tau this should have been a star up here
you guys should be catching me on this a
star big t DTaP okay it sounds like a
bunch of math but all I did was I popped
the T's and T inverses out of the
Exponential's and these guys cancel and
these guys cancel and when those cancel
what's really cool okay I dropped a T
here what's really cool about this is
that this is a constant T inverses a
constant matrix this T on the outside is
a constant so I can bring those outside
of the integral and all that's left is
an integral from 0 to infinity of e to
the a T BB star e to the a star T that's
my controllability Graham Ian in my
original coordinates that's original WC
so this equals T inverse WC T if I
mess anything up what this means is that
when I do a coordinate transformation
with this T matrix my new
controllability Graham Ian is simply T
inverse times my old controllability
Graham Ian in my original x coordinates
times T that's a pretty useful useful to
know okay so now what we're going to do
is we're gonna try to find a good T that
takes my original WC and makes it equal
to wo and equal to a diagonal matrix
that's we're gonna do I should probably
also tell you what wo does and just this
is an exercise you can just do this
yourself at home
wo hat is going to equal T star wo T
okay and this was so straight T inverse
WC t T inverse I think this was supposed
to be a t- star and I think this is a t-
star and this is a minus star let me see
about that and get back to you okay big
picture we have dynamics we're doing a
coordinate transformation we want to
know how the dynamics change and how the
controllability and observability
cramming has changed next time we're
going to design this T matrix
specifically so that these Graeme ins
have beneficial properties okay thank
you